[Music]
hello again I'm Dustin Kirkland I'm
joined now by Yoshi Tamura product
manager at Google and we are here to
talk about G visor so G visor brand new
just open sourced this week at coop con
here in Copenhagen give me the
highlights of that announcement yes
so Google Cloud just a now C visor is a
new open-source sandbox technology for
container isolation it is a very
lightweight yet provide a very strong
isolation compared to various existing
approaches interesting so you said it's
new it's new to the open-source
community
this is technology that's been in use at
Google for quite some time right correct
we have been using G Visor at Google for
a while and we're very excited to share
the technology and also in the knowledge
that we gained from there yeah so why
are why are we Google open sourcing this
project now it is mainly because
container adoption docker kubernetes now
a lot of people are using containers and
the more people use containers we
started seeing a lot of new use cases
most especially especially like
multi-tenancy
where there's one cluster with different
type of groups or even customers now the
container isolation because more
important in this kind of situation we
believe that it's a open source and G
visor which is a new proposal to the
open source community could advance the
technology in this continuous relation
space so it's really about the security
it's about sandboxing your some
containers all containers some
containers specifically on if you equus
definitely specify but if you specify
that you want stronger isolation for a
particular container yes you can
actually do this
yeah and how strong is this isolation is
it as strong as a VM we believe that it
is kind of a very closer level for sure
the other aspect I think strong in the
lightweight part we we can't we in our
testing environment it can lodge within
150 millisecond 150 milliseconds too
long exactly I know so the footprint and
also about 50 megabyte okay so it is
very lightweight and yet
strong isolations the light way so
compare that light weight to say qmu KVM
cotta yes so there are existing
approaches like you the ones that you
mentioned if you you can definitely put
the container inside a virtual machine
to provide a very strong isolation okay
the one is that what G visor is it is
actually very similar but if you look
into the detail where you can look at
least look at the blog it actually is
how highlights the key differences there
but in a nutshell the virtual machine
you actually need to run like um you
know device simulate a knows the guest
Colonel therefore the footprint Plus
also the attacking surface is still
significant Sheriff G Weiser took a
little bit different approach where you
trap the system calls and then provide a
multiple layers of security this is I
think the great part is you Peyser yeah
interesting so do you actually run a
kernel inside of the G Weiser machine it
is a very tricky question so I strongly
recommend going to the blog is a very
novel and innovative approach I think
it's these goals are being trapped
though yes and those are being executed
by the host the host kernel actually so
there is a guest user land kernel ok I
will dry this micro girl is it another
micro claim I'm taking us a technical of
perspective but it is that login it's a
very new project very creative we also
reached out to the Carter continued
community about this they were also very
welcome as you can see in a blog post we
also got the quotes from theirs team so
I think you think there's an opportunity
for the two projects to really come
together and advance the state of the
art I think that is the most exciting
part like if this fuel is so important
for our ecosystem and taking different
approaches it's definitely going to
advance the feel altogether so that is
the most exciting part of why we're open
sourcing and how what we look for toward
the future and if someone wants to get
started with this what's the best place
to get started so we also have against
the getting started section in our blog
but certainly yes going from
github you can download the source code
G visor is implementing OCI therefore it
runs on with kubernetes dock right so
you could if you're interested just go
to github and try out so it's another
runtime that kubernetes supports exec
will support it is so the runtime is
self or command it's called run SC which
is where you can replace the existing
Rossy dropping a replacement
okay so should be if you're familiar
that was cos I should be able to run it
very quickly sure and if I do this can I
run some containers in the same
kubernetes with run C and some
containers and run at a run SC context
right now the kubernetes community
especially signal we're specifying the
higher-level API call sandbox okay so
until that gets into Corona is you may
have to such as some manual points to
control that but we believe that
integration is going to come to come to
the kubernetes world very quickly that's
great that's great
so I've got a question for you yes how
did you get started in kubernetes
is a great question I will say two
points when I joined Google I was very
excited about the internal system called
borg go kubernetes like based off or or
derive from broad-based some kind of a
way that i got more got i got that
knowledge after getting google the other
aspect which is interesting is because
is before joining kubernetes team I went
to Tokyo one of my friends were saying
I'm using kubernetes I actually didn't
know about communities at time so that
was how I learn about kubernetes in 2017
interesting and another question for you
you're involved in the communities
community I certainly encounter a lot of
a lot of people in our very large and
opened community can you tell us a few
of the people that inspire you that you
find yourself working with and being
super impressed and appreciative
absolutely a little bit hesitating to
highlight my colleague at Google but it
is definitely true so Don Chan has been
super has been
inspire me quite a bit I worked with her
on G visor and also very British know
stuff she has a very technical strong
and visionary technical insight and also
a very good communication so it's just a
joy to work with her oh oh great Yoshi
thank you very much oh thank you very
much don't know where ever Gothel don't
mind you got some perfect
you